Congratulations! You've finished something really complex.
You've made your own bar charts, your own histograms, and your own scatter plots.
Isn't this a lot of fun? Isn't statistics really great?
Did you learn that by just looking at data, you can already understand a lot.
So the purpose of this unit was to empower you to instruct the computer to plot data,
and the reason why I told you this is because the very first step every statistician does
is to look at the data if you're given data.
Now on the next unit, I will give you something that'll bend your mind.
I will give you data that depending on how you look at it
will get you a very different conclusion.
Stay tuned and check out the next unit where I will bend your mind.